- How long have
Um, close to 10 years.
OK, so you've had it for 10
years, and you preserved it.
I mean, thank god you
pulled it up on the trailer
here because I could
see it was starting
to rot into the ground.
So now that you know
it's the real deal--
What's the deal?
So now, everybody's on
board with it is legit,
this is where the
switch gets flipped.
We want to buy it.
Now that it's confirmed
that it is the real van,
you know, that flips it into
another-- a whole other--
Category.
In its degraded condition,
it would be very risky to keep
it out in the open here.
And I'm always concerned about
vandalism and other things.
God only knows
what could happen.
Like, for me personally, and
I know you probably thought
about this, it's like, the
money shot for this whole thing
is the side of the van.
And the story is
extremely powerful.
But when you look
at the van itself,
even to present the van, there's
going to be a lot of work done.
Now I'm not talking
about restoring it,
but to stabilize the van.
This would all have
to be stabilized.
Right.
I mean, would you
put a number on it?
Would you sell it?
I would, yeah.
But as numbers go--
We know this is
a big decision.
I know you just--
you've had it 10 years,
it's hard to make a
decision like, right now.
I understand it's history.
But what I'm looking at
is the condition of it.
So where I'd want to
be on it is 22 grand.
I'm thinking.
So many things had to happen
to get us to this moment.
First of all, Danny
basically stumbles
on a guy that's got a
piece of rock and roll
history sitting in his yard.
Then I call my buddy, Dan
Auerbach from the Black Keys.
Dan picks up the phone and calls
Joe Perry, the man himself,
from Aerosmith.
The next thing you know, one
of the original band members
comes to look at it
and authenticates
it right on the spot.
And all of this happened
in like, two hours.
This is the universe telling
us we need to own this van.
It's epic.
I'll do 25 grand.
What?
We just got a piece of
American rock and roll history.
When 25 grand
was on the table,
I think Phil was like,
whoa, I got it, man.
You got it.
If you had the opportunity
to buy one of the biggest, most
iconic pieces of rock and
roll history for 25 grand,
hell yes you would.
Dude, I'm thinking we just
had one of the biggest score
we've had in our lifetime.
Rock and roll
started in America.
This is America's
rock and roll band.
Almost 50 years
ago, a group of guys
went on the journey of
a lifetime together.
I'm talking tens of
millions of records sold,
top 40 hits, Grammys, Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame.
And that journey
started in this band.
How cool is that?
Are you speechless?
Dude, I'm still in awe.
Now that we are the
caretakers of this piece,
we have to make good
decisions on it.
The first thing I want to do
is get the van to our metal guy
and have him assess
the situation.
It was almost like
that band has been
sitting in the woods waiting
for us to come rescue it.
If somebody told you that
this van was in the woods,
what would you say?
Dream on.
You dork.